first well we get to the newest release
from the Epstein case just earlier not
that long ago tonight a second batch of
court documents were unsealed joining us
now with all the details our very own
very own Nate Foy is with us Nate what's
the latest hey Sean in this new batch of
documents lawyers for Virginia je Frey
and Gan Maxwell discuss pictures of
Maxwell at Chelsea Clinton's wedding as
possible evidence in the 2015 civil case
Bill Clinton himself is again mentioned
by jefra in an email she wrote about a
publisher labeled VF presumably Vanity
Fair it reads quote the email it does
concern me what they want to write about
me considering that b Clinton walked
into VF and threatened them not to write
sex trafficking article about his good
friend J Clinton denies this claim
through a spokesperson attorney Alan dtz
is again mentioned in the documents
accused of having sex with an underage
girl a charge that dtz strongly denies
and tonight he's coming out saying that
there are smoking guns uh that have not
been released yet with tonight's second
batch 59 documents are now unsealed
jra's lawyer tells Fox News 240
documents are coming in total so we're
about 25% of the way through it could
take until Monday before they're all
released we'll send it back to you Sean
all right Nick n Nate Foyd thank you
tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else